hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round six of this
year's super bet chess classic it just
finished and it's uh an incredibly a
brief game uh 25 moves uh uh in total
maybe even 24. uh let me just check yeah
it's 25 but it's um a very very uh
not an it's not an everyday site that
something like this happens it's
basically as if you were uh you know
walking to maybe a supermarket minding
your own business then you step into a
puddle of mud you look at the mud you
can't believe you just stepped into a
puddle of mud and uh you know at the
moment that you are
looking up again a car hits you that
that's basically what happened in this
game and it's very very sad of course
for the losing side but for the winning
side it's great and also for us the the
viewers who enjoy the show so let's
check it out and see
what this is all about and again it
features the names of indian defense
that transposes into rogozin but uh
still very very good stuff so maxime
opens with d4 we have knight to f6 c for
e6 knights to c3 and bishop to b4 now
lebron goes for the names of indian
knight to f3 and d5 this transposes it
into aragosan defense bishop to g5 and
now h6 is the most popular idea here the
level one goes for d captures on c4 and
this is uh i think becoming a
increasingly popular uh you you want to
play c5 you want to attack white central
d for pawn and also you will have the a5
square available for your queen you will
put more pressure on c3 and also that
bishop on g5 might be an issue in some
lines so here we have e4 grabbing the
center uh notice that the e4 pawn can be
captured if knight captures an e4 you
are grabbing a pawn but then you blunder
your queen so don't do that so here we
have c5 this is the absolute best idea
bishop captures on c4 and now c captures
on d4 so i like like we've discussed
knight captures on d4 and now bishop
captures in c3 so we will give up the
bishop for tonight the mess of white
spawn structure b captures on c3 and the
now queen to a5 attacking the c3 pawn
and the bishop and g5 and here are many
moves are possible some of the nicer
ones for example you could capture on f6
black will counter on c3 deliver check
and you can play king to f1 let's say g
captures on f6 and rook to c1 so this is
one of the options you're going to play
queen the a5 now let's say h4 you want
to play rook to
h3 bring the rook into the game it's a
very double-edged and black shouldn't
have
any problems playing this so
instead of this you could also play
knight to b5 you guarded the c3 pawn
also you are threatening knight to d6
check so what can black play here we're
going to play a6 allow this check knight
d6 check king e7
and now again you have a problem your c3
pawn is hanging and also the bishop here
is hanging so bishop to f4 is the
uh the the the move you want to play you
add more protection to the knight here
and you are preventing queen captures on
c3 because if queen captures on c3 now
we move the bishop back with tempo
and now there is not much for for black
to do let's say queen a3 we're gonna
play e5 ended now there is no good
square for the knight if
you go back with the knight then it's a
free bishop uh you can't really go
forward you could play knight d5 but
then queen g4 and the position is just
uh dead lost for black so you have to be
very very careful here uh instead bishop
the b5 check is played here maxime
delivers a nice check
we have knight b to d7 and now comes the
bishop captures on f6 we have queen
captures on c3 with check king to e2 and
this is very interesting there are
thousands of games where king to f1 was
played in the database when i say
thousands i mean
and sixty-eight uh but levon plays king
to e2 and this is now super weird why
would you do this uh probably you wanna
uh meet queen to beat you check with
queen to d2 and then if a queen trade
happens you wanna have your king nicely
in the center of the board and while you
could play g captures on f6 uh
then you allow rook to c1 then if queen
to b to check you can block with rook to
c2 so it looks uh like white might have
something here so instead we have queen
to be to check queen to d2 and
interestingly uh here king f1 and king
the e3 are known moves uh but queen to
d2 the move that maxime played is a new
move so now it is only as of move 13
that we have a completely new game so
queen captures on d2 elevon trades here
king captures and the g captures an f6
and i'll just rocate the c1 so if you
look at the position now uh levon is up
upon however maxime is up in development
and his uh
position is maybe maybe more uh
enjoyable to play level and has a double
f pawn but it doesn't appear to be a
weakness here as you do control a lot of
squares so it's uh for max seem to prove
that this is anything for white so here
we have castles levon castles the safety
also it will be easier to bring the rook
into the game the king is on the d file
rook to c7 now going for this very nice
rook lift now the threat is just bishop
captures knight we're going to win a
piece here so rook to d8 defending the
knight and now king e3 we want to get
the king away from the
uh open d file knight to b6 and now
knight to b3 uh we have f5 challenging
this
pawn here of course we want to get rid
of our doubled pawn so once we trade
here we're just going to be up a clean
pawn so bishop back to d3
and now rook to b8 now you're going to
be able to move your bishop as the rook
also helps
in the defense of the b7 pawn uh and
here maksim has to play f3 you you can
play also some like rogue one you could
play f3 there are a couple of moves to
consider here uh levon's position is
better as he's just up upon now maxine
doesn't really have
any serious compensation for the pawn
but maxine plays f4 and here lemon has a
really really awesome move that's kind
of the idea of stepping into the mod uh
this f4 move by by maxine uh and levon
plays e5 and now what has happened here
of course levon wants to play e captures
an f4 check the king will not be able to
capture because the king has to keep an
eye on the bishop on d3 so uh basically
if you play something like rook h to c1
we're going to capture on f4 and once
the king moves we're going to develop
the bishop and it's a
very very hard position for white to
play let's say captures an f5 bishop to
d5 and there is really uh
well there's just not not a good plan
here for white so instead after e5 we
have f captures on e5 but now levon
executes pawn to f4 with check again the
pawn cannot be captured as the bishop
would hang so king to d2 and now comes
um
aking to e2 also very very uh
bad square because bishop g4 check and
then you just allow black to further
develop so instead after this um
f4 check king to d2 and now bishop to e6
gaining more control over the c4 square
so now you have to be careful knight to
c4 check you will not be able to capture
as the uh the bishop is pinned so king
to c3 and now rook beat the c8
activating the the final piece rook
captures rook captures with check and
now you have to go back into d2 the game
continues and the black is uh
much much better here however maxine
played king to d4 and this is now a
terrible terrible square this is the uh
getting getting hit by by the car part
so feel free to pause the video and uh
try to find the absolute best uh winning
idea for levon basically the only
winning idea but it is one that is most
certainly
sufficient
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh realizing that
white has just stumbled into a mating
net and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is night the a4 uh
here the knight on the rim is not a grim
but a rather a grim reaper if you will
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh uh maxime definitely
didn't and here his king is uh out of
squares you can see that this pawn
covers the e3 square the knight covers
the uh c3 and c5 squares bishop covers
d5 and c4 so the white king has no
squares and rook to d8 will be checkmate
and since you cannot stop this uh maxine
just resigned and that's basically the
story of this game you could try giving
up some material let's say you play
bishop to c4 but we're just going to
capture it rook captures on c4 king d3
let's say knight b2 check king will move
king to d to rook characters here
everything just falls apart and of
course uh you do not have
enough to play this or if you try
something like maybe knight to c5 uh we
can just ignore you uh for example
knight c5 we still deliver this rook 38
check 97 rook captures on d7 checkmate
as there are no squares uh for the
for the white king so this is really
incredible stuff
and tough uh tough luck for for maxine
so he had something in mind i guess it
didn't work levon was extremely well
prepared uh and uh giving up that pawn
for some sort of an initiative didn't
really
prove to be uh relevant at any point so
he was basically just upon down uh but
yeah the the entire game can be uh
summarized basically into two parts uh
uh
this uh
f4 move by maxime that allowed e5 which
is just a beautiful beautiful move to
spot if you don't spot this black really
doesn't have all that much but once e5
is played uh then white is just in a
terrible position which makes it uh more
likely that you will uh you know make an
even greater mistake like king to d4
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to rodolfa nrclb and i
would like to thank claudio bravely and
alessandro bossi and yoga spotty
donating because it is the strongest
move appear solva ken and tarek aldawal
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot to really appreciate it uh as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this spectacular event
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day